it's great to be joined by attorney Mike
Papantonio co-host of ring of fire radio
and also the host of America's lawyer on
RT which premiered last night for people
who don't know the concept here Pat
because it's a really different concept
for a program what is it that people
will see on the show well there's so
many stories that a corporate media
their advertisers will not a order them
don't tell these stories basically if
it's a pharmaceutical that's killing
people in Pfizer's one of their
advertisers or merck is one of the
advertisers say NBC CBS ABC basically
they get the they get the order don't
tell the story if it's going to hurt
sales uh so you you you really can't
tell stories that matter to consumers if
it's Wall Street who is who's stealing
from mom-and-pop investors it's tough to
tell that story because Goldman Sachs
and Morgan all of the big folks on Wall
Street are advertising through corporate
media same way same way with
environmental cases you know if DuPont
for example is destroying an entire
ecosystem you really can't tell that
story if you're on corporate media
because the advertisers won't let you
and I've had first-hand experience with
that I mean where we were where I was
told you know we tried to tell a story
about something called yellow wood that
we were talking about the fact that it
contained arsenic and we were shut down
immediately on MSNBC yet talk about that
because you were at the time a fairly
regular guest on MSNBC weren't you and
then you went on and you started telling
the story and all of a sudden it was
visit a year or more that you just did
not get invited back I think it might
have been a couple years yeah back then
I was doing in between there I was doing
fox news during the time I wasn't I was
a liberal on Fox yeah but I told the
story about something that was called
yellow wood and it was where they were
using this this wood that we alleged and
I think showed clearly i had had content
of arsenic in it but unfortunately we're
using the wood for children's
playgrounds and that kind of wood
is fine if you're building a foundation
for a house that you know you don't want
the wood Dorado if you're building a
pier that reaches out into into waterway
that that's good it actually works for
that but the point is you don't use that
for children's playgrounds and so we did
a segment as Joe Scarborough and I did a
segment and the next day we I got a call
from Phil Griffin whose well I didn't
Joe got the call from phil griffin
saying what's what's up here and it was
almost as if we had to go back on and do
a recount the story which I which I
refuse to do and so that's pretty
typical of what you run into with
corporate media there it's all about
money they they have no responsibility
to to really telling investigative
stories I mean just look at the tobacco
problem where you had 60 minutes that we
even hedged on telling the story about
tobacco and the dangers of how it causes
cancer and that's even after the the
CEOs for 12 different companies raise
the right hand and committed perjury
from the Congress lied to Congress about
the dangers but still you can't get you
cannot get corporate media to tell these
stories anymore oftentimes that's how
somebody about a legal show they imagine
you know a panel of four people yelling
about whether someone is guilty or not
guilty of some depraved crime against
kids or something like that america's
lawyer is a totally different type of
legal show i mean you're talking about
specific corporations and you're talking
about some of the cases that attorneys
are involved in can you give us a couple
of examples of what we can for example
the first show we talked about Johnson &
Johnson's powder where we actually
showed the documents that came from
their file cabinets that showed that
they absolutely knew of the dangers of
ovarian cancer relating to tout powder
so we don't just I begin the show David
with a short opening statement about six
or seven minutes but in there I'm
actually showing the documents that I'm
relying on I'm not not asking anybody to
take my word for anything we actually
show them the documents and then we move
right into the lawyer who might be
handling it and they talk more about the
documents and what's showing up in court
so we started off with that case we
started off with Erin Brokovich on
the Flint Michigan coverup and we
actually we focused on the idea that you
had Rick Snyder up there that was that
was covering up the dangers of this
water that children were drinking by the
gallons for a year and the amount of
lead that was contained in it why it was
covered up how it was covered up and
Erin Brockovich handled that issue so
that we it's kind of gloves it's totally
gloves off David there's no there's
nothing warm and fuzzy about what we do
we go after the other side and then we
end the story we in the show talk about
the good the positive stories that are
out there where there's been great
developments in the law on behalf of
consumers and again consumers simply
don't have a chance to hear those
stories either how is your legal
community given the types of cases that
that you work on and try preparing for
the incoming Trump administration and by
that I mean you know for example the
Dakota access pipeline which both Donald
Trump and incoming a secretary of energy
Rick Perry have financial connections to
Scott Pruett at the EPA a guy charged
with environmental protection who has a
multi-decade record of doing the exact
opposite i mean do you think that there
are implications in terms of the work
that you do from the incoming cabinet
well it's just going to create a lot of
work I mean we've been through this
before for example after the Bush
administration we started seeing more
pharmaceutical cases where dangerous
drugs were killing people literally by
the thousands whether it was a a birth
control pill that was causing and it was
causing blood clots or excuse me that
was causing strokes and women whether it
was an anticoagulant drug that was
causing there was supposed to be used to
avoid blood clots that was causing death
and people by just bleeding bleeding out
so we saw a lot of that come out of the
bush administration and oddly enough
Clinton as well because there was such
an effort to deregulate their FDA was
the the the FDA was basically neutered
in their ability to be able to do
anything and they voluntarily
participated with the pharmaceutical
industry because they were getting jobs
you see they would FDA would get a job
they would move
through the process and they would say
yeah we're going to allow this drug to
go on the market next thing you know
that person is working with the drug
company so we're going to see the same
thing and it's going to be the younger
lawyers of five six seven years from now
they have to clean up this mess again in
the meantime we're gonna go to court
every time we have to slow everything
down as much as possible as far as
america's lawyer is concerned you know
anytime that there's a program that that
starts a savvy media consumer would say
okay well let's explore what conflicts
of interest could arise based on the
advertisers on that program that's going
to be very specifically not an issue
with with america's lawyer isn't it no
no that's one reason obviously I agree
agreed to do this I mean there is no
conflict of interest at all I mean we're
not you know obviously some of the cases
that we're talking about we're going to
be involved with because we've been
doing this for 35 years it will be we
will have tried some of those cases but
you don't have to take our word for it
we'll have people besides such me
talking about the case and as far as
advertising they don't they don't really
advertise that that's they have the same
advantage of the BBC hat or whether
they're able to tell a story without
having an advertiser make a telephone
call saying you have to take that story
down because it's going to affect sales
it's really odd right now you're in the
midst of you know you've got the
Democrats primarily beating on Russia
for hacking weed there's at this point I
think you conclude the same thing I have
there's all this innuendo not a Miss
anonymous there's anonymous that so far
I've seen no proof of anything but
nevertheless it's a good talking point
for the Democrats who feel like they
have to blame the failure election on
the FBI call me on Bernie Sanders on
wikileaks on Russians on progressive
media on the misogynist on Millennials
on fake news I mean we've seen it all
yeah I think I you know I think I agree
with you on in terms of you know there's
plenty of blame here that should be
inward looking at the same time you know
I've disagreed with the the right-wing
idea that hey that the CIA was wrong on
Iraq and we can't trust them now either
on this Russia thing because it's sort
of a false notion that the Bush
administration miss
used what the CIA had actually said so
that talking point specifically i think
is one that's being really misused by by
the right to discredit the CIA unfairly
i don't know what you think of that well
my response is the CIA is not a moot
bunch of morons I mean they had the
right to speak up they didn't speak up
even after they even after Powell in
rice showed up in front of the UN with
this fraud game that they played about
about yellowcake uranium they knew the
lie yeah and they chose to keep their
mouth shut in thousands tens and tens of
thousands of people died because of it I
have very little respect for the CIA
very little and I'm not equating this
with it but you know it's not just it's
just not people like me that are
doubting the CIA it's it's the FBI
doubting the CIA it's the it's the it's
an organization that runs all of the
security entities that say we're not
buying into this Russian hacking so we
have to see more I mean and I and I
think it makes me angry the anguish to
see the Democrats using this is some
type of prop by we as far as why here we
failed it's in sensing to me yep i agree
with you i mean that the bottom line is
even if all of the allegations are true
if you didn't have such a candidate with
this level of baggage fifty-eight
thousand votes in three states would not
have swung the election to begin with
that sort of where i end up on it mm-hmm
exactly not only that but it's kind of a
misdirection david we see it in court
all the time where the defense lawyer we
present these horrible documents and the
defense to the dot defense to the case
is well yeah these documents are bad but
let's talk about where Papantonio got
those documents isn't that matters you
see that the emails were horrible and so
rather than addressing that they want to
blame it on somebody else yet to me it's
just insane and unfortunately
rank-and-file democrats are buying into
it and it's making them look foolish
america's lawyer premiered on RT last
night we've been speaking with the
show's host attorney Mike Papantonio
always great to talk to you thank you
David I appreciate it